Courtney vanderson joins us this morning
hey what's up Courtney how you doing
I'm good thanks for having me of course
thank you for joining us so what was
that energy like when you had that home
opener you guys took home the w
ow oh it was so awesome you know it had
been there's been so much build up
coming to the home opener and we are so
excited to kind of be out there in front
of our fans and you know put on a show
for them
now you were with the Chicago Sky you
helped them win their first championship
so you bring that Championship pedigree
to this squad what is it that you're
going to bring over to this team to help
the Liberty try to do the same
yeah well I remember how um just how
special the first one is for a franchise
you know we experienced that in Chicago
and that's exactly what I I Look to
bring here is just a little hard work
grit I you know my my strength is
getting people involved and of course we
have a lot of threats so um you know
just look to play in a fun brand of
basketball and high energy High pace
speaking of threats your teammate
Brianna Stewart scored a franchise 45
points 45 which was crazy had everybody
going wild and here's something that she
said she said it's much better to be on
Courtney's side than against her so what
is it like when you have to build that
chemistry with other superstars along
the way
yeah you know there's a learning curve
to it it takes time but um you know
fortunate for me Stewie there's not much
learning curve it's pretty easy
um because you know Stewie is just a
once in a lifetime type of player she's
she makes everybody around her better
she makes my job easier and she really
put on a show for everyone in her home
opener but I think you're going to see a
lot more of that this season
you played in Russia for four years with
Brittany Greiner what has it been like
to see her after she's been released
yeah it's just been so amazing to see
her back on the floor but most
importantly just smiling again you know
you can really just feel the energy that
that she has when she enters her room
and that's something that I'm so glad
that is just the world can see now
because that's something that's really
special about BG
you know women playing overseas has been
a topic of conversation and then one
thing that comes from that conversation
is you know why don't they make the
money that they need to make here so
they don't have to go pursue another
season somewhere else you know we saw
women's March Madness and the ratings
were up the most it's ever been we know
that people love the sport the games are
as competitive as ever and the athletes
are phenomenal why do you believe there
still is that pay Gap and why do you
believe that women still have to go play
elsewhere to make the money they deserve
well women's basketball is still growing
and it's at its highest point right now
I think people are really starting to
respect and watch it and I think that
we're still growing as a league
especially in the W we're still fairly
young and you know we're making strides
and it's baby steps it's not going to
happen overnight but um I think that
we're in the right direction and you
know people are going to come and see
but we need people in the seats and
that's that's how it's going to happen
we need people in the seats and I also
believe we as media need to do a better
job of telling the stories just like the
NBA we need to dive into the lives of
these athletes so fans feel like they
know the athletes and we will continue
to do that thank you so much for joining
us Courtney vandersloot and you can
watch Connecticut Sun take on the New
York Liberty right here at 1 pm Eastern
on CBS and streaming on Paramount Plus